so we delivered the the second Fox by
owners report and there was two or three
aspects of that one was it helped us
understand why some of these terrible
incidents happened and before I go
further I just want to say again I'm
deeply deeply sorry for what those
victims had to go through it was
absolutely horrendous the fox women's
reports helped us understand a bit more
about why some of these things happened
it also made a number of recommendations
35 recommendations about things that we
could do to change a process our culture
the organization and we've accepted
those in full and then of course as we
announced on Friday we've got 60 days to
come back to the members with a plan at
egm in June where members organization
is for them to vote on that plan and are
we fit for the future
the fox Williams report
um
well the organizers in high school isn't
where the extent of the culture problems
there were incidents yes
they direct the board members
in terms of drug use and super practice
sexual harassment of U.P to manage
internally talk about that happen with
an organization which is supposed to be
about that well I think that the the
drug case happened I believe at one at
this boat party there was two incidents
there and two others that we found out
about I think the report said there was
no evidence of widespread drug taking
within the CBI which was the allegation
and we've dealt with that I believe the
other incidents uh again the two more
serious incidents are with the police
and we can't comment further on those
and we were made aware of a number of
incidents which we acted upon I think
what we've seen is that when we knew
about things we did act upon them but
the fact that serious things happened
and we didn't know about them tells us
there's something wrong with account
culture people women found that they
couldn't come forward the voice wasn't
heard and that's the concern to us so we
have to change that I think what we've
had a system of in the past is a an
organization that was over complex with
its eyes too many layers too many
managers not trained enough of these
sensitive people issues that people and
cultural agenda was not top of mind that
wasn't you know the HR Director didn't
sit on exec committee the board didn't
hear very much about people issues we've
addressed that through this report as
well so a combination of a number of
feelings that led together to be a more
serious overall feeling more honest it
was a
say that you try to deal with
allegations sexual harassment resolve
them within the business how can that
ever be right
but well I think there was a number of
incidents that have been dealt with in
the past and without getting into
details of incidents there's always a
spectrum of sanction at the end of that
in any organization if you look at that
that's what you'd expect you don't rush
to dismiss people immediately any terms
of instant I think what we're seeing is
that you know we have to go for it for a
much more Zero Tolerance culture we must
make we must actually get much more
severe in dealing with these things so I
think where we had resolution before
that was agreed by both parties we're
still saying that that's probably not
enough and we have to have a zero
tolerance culture here are you in
communication with the police yes we are
but we have been cooperating with the
police over these two very serious
incidents is it going to take police
action do you think to let you try and
wipe this locally I do I look I think
that's a separate issue I think I think
the police will determine if there's a
case to answer there and if there is
they will prosecute that that's out of
our hands and if there's not a case to
answer with nothing to investigate so I
think we're more focused on what we can
do and that's about rebuilding for us
it's about rebuilding the trust that we
obviously lost with with the members who
left us in on Friday it's rebuilding
trust with the political stakeholders
because what I do know is that in every
major economy in Europe they've got a
CBI equivalent business needs one voice
to be able to talk to the government the
chancellor said that today they need one
single voice to talk to we accept it
today that's not us but the work that
we're doing over the next 60 days is to
rebuild trust in this organization and
become that one voice for British
business a couple more if I may
um the recommendations and the action
you're taking is quite technical an HR
processes where people sit within the
organization that sounds like slow work
is that going to be enough given the
speed with which
this is the rug has been pulled from
beneath no I think it's a very fair
comment look culture change is never a
fast quick fix it really does take time
but let me just tell you how quickly
we're moving here we invited 10 firms to
help us with this work last week we've
narrowed it down to two we'll appoint
one of those firms by the end of this
week and we will start that working
Monday so we will jump start the working
culture rebuilding that starts with
listening to all of our employees it
starts with listening to their views and
culture and this is a fairly tried and
tested program that we were going
through so that will start immediately
the new director General she's well
regarded clearly by you she has a good
reputation but she is part of the CBI
historically during this time is it
possible to reboot with the director
General who was in the building when
this was going on I think so rain was a
part of the CBI for quite a while she
left at seba out and went outside look
rain having been part of the CBI knows
what's good about it she knows what's
bad about it she was a champion for
women's rights women's advancement and I
think made a lot of progress for Women
Within the CBI hence the great gender
balance that I've got today railings
also highly respected as an economist
highly respectable politicians highly
respected by our members our members our
members and their employees were
delighted when we announced that she was
coming back okay and yourself you've had
some criticism as well
listen I've been criticized that goes
with the job that goes with being the
ultimate accountability for this
organization I am the President and I
will take whatever brick bats are out
there but it's my job to help resolve
this to get us out the situation we're
in just now it's not for me to walk away
I say it's too hard Chancellor told me
this morning there's no point in talking
to CBI can you change that I did what he
said is that there's no point in talking
to the CBI at this moment we want to
present to him and in 60 days time this
is why you should be talking to us and
coming in for an election with an
election less than 15 months away
British business is screaming out for a
voice to talk to government and the
opposition